lien du dessous au coeur des marais de
bourges les précipitations ont fait
sortir la voiselle de son lit la rivière
en crue il ya quelques jours à creuser
de nombreuses ravines sur le chemin
pédestre plusieurs terrains cultivés
appartenant à des particuliers sont
désormais gorgée d'eau est là avec les
crus conlie aub vous voyez c'est tout
est parti n'est pas aux voisins la tehon
leur jardin je sais pas comment ils vont
faire pour s'en sortir que voulez vous
que quelqu'un vienne dans son terrain
maintenant dans l'état où il est les
travaux effectués en 2010 pour
consolider les digues ne suffisent pas
les inondations répétitif ces dernières
années pourrait à terme mettre en péril
les marais les maraîchers qui sont
inondées régulièrement ils en ont marre
et il risque c'est d'abandonner se
décourage et il s est c'est le riz c'est
de revoir plein de parcelles retourner à
l'état d'origine à des friches les 1200
propriétaires qui se répartissent les
135 ha desmarais se disent découragés
contribuant en grande partie à
l'entretien et la mise en valeur de ce
territoire via l'agriculture urbaine il
souhaiterait obtenir un plus grand
soutien des pouvoirs publics